human behavior is so predictable let me
tell you how you can profit from this in
crypto when the market is dead everyone
is so afraid and nobody wants to buy but
when the market is up and Bitcoin is at
all-time highs everybody fomos in the
top you need to be the person like me
who's getting paid and is buying at the
bottom of the market when everyone else
is afraid rather than being the person
that runs in at the top of the market
and eventually becomes everyone else's
exit liquidity where people who bought
early will just dump on you this is what
the big whales they buy at the bottom of
the market in Readiness for the bull
market because they know that your human
behavior is so predictable and you're
going to fomo in at the top of the
market they'll use you as exit liquidity